c'est ici que sera construite la
nouvelle usine de pile pour véhicule
électrique de Volkswagen le travail de
défricheur est déjà commencé on démolit
des maisons et de nombreux arbres ont
également été abattus ces terrains font
partie d'un parc industriel qui s'étend
sur 1500 heures l'équivalent de 852
terrains de soccer et la majorité de ces
terres sont parmi les meilleurs terres
agricoles en Ontario ce que regrette
cette agriculteur qu'on perde 319 autres
par jour alors si on continue comme ça
on n'aura pas de terre dans une centaine
d'années en Ontario pour pousser les
produits agricoles
reconnaît l'importance économique
d'avoir l'usine de Volkswagen en Ontario
mais il déplore qu'on est choisi 500
mètres sa construction on est sur notre
meilleur terrain agricole dans le
province alors si on commence à mettre
des usines sur cette terre on perd
labilité d'avoir des produits pour la
population canadienne et antérieure
l'agriculteur pense que l'usine amènera
un développement supplémentaire qui
mettra en péril encore plus de terres
agricoles dans la région comme des
autoroutes des maisons et des commerces
ça prend plus de terre c'est non
seulement l'usine c'est tout ce qui
arrive avec les développements qui ne
devraient pas avoir lieu 17 à Grenoble
protection des textes agricoles qui sont
déjà identifiés le choix des Saint-Omer
était important bien réfléchi selon ce
représentant de l'industrie automobile
c'est l'endroit idéal pour l'usine d'un
style parce que c'est facilement
accessible parce qu'il y a une forte
culture manufacturière dans cette
municipalité par ailleurs les retombées
économiques seront très importantes pour
la région selon le gouvernement ontarien
qui compte investir 500 millions de
dollars dans le projet
de son côté le gouvernement fédéral
compte investir 13 milliards de dollars
mais Christine Calvin croit pour sa part
que les différents gouvernements
devraient aussi mettre plus d'argent
pour assurer la pérennité de
l'agriculture en Ontario
parce que on protégera la terre la
construction de l'usine doit commencer
l'an prochain et se terminer en 2027
mais le débat sur l'utilisation des
terres agricoles en Ontario risque de
continuer encore longtemps ici en arrêt
Triki Radio-Canada sympa